foreign
okay
um my wife is calling me
now she's not all right
um
I did not hang up on she hung up on me
uh we'll start off the I'll open today's
public hearing uh for the house election
law committee on hb40 we'll start with
the pledge
um representative Lane would you like to
um
I pledge allegiance yeah uh okay
um we'll start off with hb40 which is
the only thing we have until we execute
11. um uh representative Horgan I
believe this is your bill
um if you want to come up and welcome to
election law and introduce the bill I
only have one pink card for this so if
anybody else wishes to speak on this uh
thank you very much I mean it's not just
my bill I've got several co-sponsors on
it but um I've uh and it's been around
the block a few times there's uh your
community researcher has a excellent
memo which I uh
which has a lot of good information
about it um
and uh
first of all I guess one of the people
submitted testimony
um
so I don't know if he's the other pink
card uh there's he went on and on a lot
a lot about made up a lot of stuff about
the definition of residency which wasn't
true but um you can worry about that
later
um the definitions of residency is
fairly is uh fairly simple as the memo
explains and this bill would make a uh
minor changes definitely there's a
residency which uh
hasn't in practice made a major
difference one way or the other because
they we I'm putting it okay so anyway so
it's essentially identical to hpe 538
2021 which came before the election law
committee two years ago and that was uh
deemed itl by a narrow tendinite margin
on March 30th 2021 that was the year
that we were
that was the spring that we were having
our uh
Full House sessions at the Sportsplex in
Merrimack
um
and that was one of several dozen bills
all of them it out in committee which
never got a floor vote which kind of
violated house rules and president
because supposedly
every Bill gets a vote on the floor but
um
you know I
could have brought it back in 2022 but I
decided to wait decided not to do it
last year but I'm back um with it this
year because
um essentially the reason it didn't go
the floor is all the bills were they
pulled out a few of the bills that were
it held in committee which they thought
might be overturned and all the ones
which were unlike to be overturned were
just never voted on which uh
kind of irregular but that was a strange
time and so no hard feelings about that
so here I am again with it
it's also a combination of two bills
which I sponsored which many co-sponsors
uh well
and I've got several this year in 2019
they both past the House and Senate them
being vetoed by governor sununu and then
um
one of those two bills HP 106 also
covered the same ground so Senate bill
which the government the same governor
also vetoed so it's uh in that part of
the bill is at the end of the very long
bill before the committee today it's uh
covered by section section 16 out of 18.
and um actually that's a good thing to
refer to just to uh refresh your
memories on the definition of residence
which regardless of whether existing law
applies or whether we put the minor
change I'm proposing
in this bill either way it's a very
simple definition which is much simpler
than
what you may hear from opponents of the
bill if any step four if there are even
going to be any here in the committee
room today so you know it's uh
it's a very uh you know it's a much
simpler concept
um it's a common word that obviously
everybody it's a common word but it's a
much simpler meaning legally than people
sometimes try to say it is so that's um
basically so anyway so it's
I perceive it and rightly or wrongly but
um others do perceive it as a uh being
especially uh
being especially directed against
college students and their right to vote
which they have like any other citizen
they're not the only voters who are
adversely affected by the chances of
voting rights to law which we're trying
to undo
but um and the basically the bottom line
is
every citizen over the age of 18 has the
right to vote in the community where he
or she lives regardless of why he or she
moved there and regardless of how long
it goes that's pretty clear even in
existing law it'll be even clearer if
you pass this bill
and um it's also guaranteed by federal
voting rights law the U.S and state
constitutions etc etc so that's um
and uh but I'll quote our state
constitution it says
um this is part of article 11
part one it says all elections are to be
free and every inhabited estate 18 years
of age and upwards shall have an equal
right to vote in any election every
person shall be considered an inhabitant
for the purposes of voting the town Ward
or unincorporated place where he has a
stone missile and if you by the
definition of residence domicile
um
anybody who's anybody is physically
present in the town most of the year
is a residence and they claim down the
domicile and there's also certain
exceptions uh
where somebody who's temporarily at
least in their view temporarily away not
that anybody knows how temporary how
permanent their current residence is but
um anybody
you know so anyway so students college
students particular and others who may
be considered uh not as permanent as
other residents they're still they're
still there they're still
living in the community that's still
physically president they're still
paying taxes in most place they're
working in the community
et cetera et cetera so everything that
applies to a non-student applies to a
college student and
and of course there are others military
personnel uh
military personnel people who maybe are
holding down come here to hold down temp
jobs and may or may not uh get permanent
jobs out of it etc etc
um
so any residents of that sort
they have the right to vote in the place
where they're living and so that's
basically what my bill is about we're
just trying to uh
we're just trying to put the voting law
the back it was before certain I think
unwise changes were made back in uh
starting about 2012 and there actually
is a
Senate bill which covers some of the
same ground which uh passed the senate
election law committee unanimously which
has that's a group of five Senators who
have a very wide view of uh views and
it's on the consent calendar so
not that we talk maybe I'm not supposed
to talk about what goes on the other
side of the wall but like some of the
there's going to be changes in this area
anyway so but I think
this bill I think is a complete set of
changes that are needed so
with that I'd be happy to take any
questions
from the committee representative Hamlet
thank you Mr chair and thank you Miss Mr
Horgan thanks so in Section 8 on page 20
uh wait down so this is about
centralized voter registration database
and at the very bottom of the page it
says upon the effective date of
subparagraph a the Secretary of State
shall cease any activity or data
transfer with the kansas-based
interstate voter registration to
cross-check program so that must be the
program we're in now
so and I don't know very much about that
program so this would allow us to
uh enroll in in a centralized
voter registration database
I'm just asking for clarification well
my understanding is you may get a clear
clarification from the secondary state
who's sitting in the front row and
probably will be happy to speak
um but that was a that was a program
that was uh that's a program that's been
around for several years which is highly
problematic had a lot of false positives
and so forth so we're pulling out of
that one but if a better one exists we
can join that one that's uh
at least I was my understanding why I
signed off on the bill with that
language on there so
yeah thank you
further questions
representative weary
thank you chair and thank you
representative Morgan
um just a couple of questions on page
five
and going into page six you talked uh
the language that has been added is or
to which I intend to return after a
temporary absence what what is the
temporary absence and do you have a
duration for that or what is what's the
intent behind that well that's um I mean
it's the idea is that a person who has
multiple residences as many as do um
can have only one of those residences
there as their domiciles so in the case
of a
and we're talking a lot about college
students they're a good example they uh
some of them vote
in their quote unquote back home
location and some of them choose to vote
in their college town basically
depending on where
they feel more of a connection to the
political activity in that community and
I know when I was a college student
which was many many years ago as you can
tell by my hair color
I uh voted when I was in undergraduate I
voted here in Durham that is going to
school in New York City because
partially because my father was a member
of the legislature and then when I went
off to grad school I
did it the other way around I just voted
wherever it was I was living while going
to school so there are students are one
class of Voters on others who have
multiple residences and um you know they
have the right to choose it's up to them
to choose which one is the one they feel
is more permanent and more like where
they want to be voting and been
civically engaged
follow-up please thank you um all right
uh thank you for that uh explanation
um and then on the on the
let's see I guess this would be page one
where you say a person's claim uh added
text in bold there bold italic
um a person's claim of dominant lines 10
through 12 a person's claim of domicile
for voting purposes shall not be
conclusive of the person's residence for
any other legal purpose isn't isn't that
sort of redundant with
the wording in the paragraph above or
why the additional that was distinctions
I mean we're
the uh I think that was language that
was in that RSA back before we started
back before we started trying to uh
trying to improve it but trying that was
trying to decouple uh your voting Dom
LaSalle from things well especially uh
like in-state tuition for uh the
university and then also just trying to
decouple a little bit from things like
driver's licenses or so forth so so
there's our there are
yeah so the end of course our people you
have multiple and as I said before it's
lots of people have multiple residences
so
representatively
thank you Mr
Mr President Horrigan back to the
language on page five to six about where
which to which I intend to return after
a temporary absence my recollection and
you and I'm just asking you if this is
still correct was that also covered
people who like were residences
residency who had medical residencies
who had to be out of state for a short
period of time or whose jobs took them
out of state for a time but still wanted
to be there yeah exactly yes is that
correct yes that's part of it okay and
Military personality right and also my
understanding would that would have
covered people who we affectionately
refer to as snowbirds yes okay thank you
I just want to make sure that was still
yeah okay thanks
further questions
I do have one um in your testimony you
said that this would allow specifically
college students to choose where to vote
based on their political activity
did I misunderstand that
you I mean
I mean you may be maybe misconstruing a
little bit better but like it's anybody
and that applies to college students
anybody else some of them feel uh you
know
some of them are more engaged with the
community they're living in right then
as opposed to the community they came
from in which they may or may not return
at some point in the future so that's uh
yes so they're the same right as anybody
else who's done you know domicile or
even like say a medical resident of
course that's still probably a form of
student but like say a medical residents
say if they
go to say the uh
Cornell Medical College in New York and
then they get assigned to Dartmouth
Health you know they may
they may be more interested in what's
going on in uh in New Hampshire than
they were back like yeah back when they
were in New York City at Cornell Medical
College or whatever so that's that
probably I mean that I would say yes
that is probably uh
I mean I know like some people may think
that's an undesirable thing but yes you
you that's true of like the snowbirds
too some care more about
what's going on up up here in New
Hampshire and so maybe care more about
what's going on down in the place in
Florida they have like
you know they have a certain amount of
leeway deciding which one of those two
places is there uh is there uh voting
domicile so
it's any other questions from the
committee uh yes representative Bay
thank you chairman
um thank you for taking my question so
this uh bill it it goes both ways right
so for example uh I have a college
student who chose to go to school in
Hawaii
and So based on this bill that she could
choose whether she where she has a
deeper I guess political connection so I
want her to vote here because I want her
to vote for me so yes well yeah that's
that's legitimate and I have to confess
I did the same thing when I had a family
member doing the same thing you're doing
now like uh years and years ago even
though I was certainly also involved in
uh political things going on down there
in New York city so that's perfectly
legitimate and actually
this is gratuitous mention of Hawaii but
there was a
one of the court cases which is
mentioned in the memo and which is
newberger versus Peterson which was uh
50 years ago but it's still like a
a important uh
important still like uh it's still like
a very important case which was um
Peterson was Walter Peterson the former
who was the Attorney General of New
Hampshire at the time and was later to
governor and the president of unh and
many other great things but um newburger
was a student at Dartmouth who wanted to
register to vote
in in Hanover because that was and he
was before he was hand over he's
originally from from uh from Hawaii and
then one thing special about his
situation was that his parents had died
so he was an orphan so he
and he had no immediate intention of
returning to Hawaii and he may have done
so at some point so like he really had
nowhere else to vote you know so
a lot of times we go on about how saying
well these college students they should
vote absentee quote unquote back home
not on all of them are eligible to vote
back home even if they wanted to and
that was the case for Mr neuberger for
example 50 years ago and it's still the
case for some students today thanks
any further questions
okay you're seeing none um thank you
representative Horgan I only have one
more pink card uh Secretary of State
Scanlon
the big man himself we're not getting
the deputies or anybody there we're
thank you Mr chairman the members of the
committee I'm David Scanlon Secretary of
State
um this bill has a lot in it and to the
extent that it removes some of the
language related to the passage of sb3
which the court has found
unconstitutional uh I would agree with
removing those sections from the statute
but if the bill is confusing in other
respects and you know one of the one of
the things that jumped out at me right
away
is if you look at uh
on page four
line six
uh the statute that is being addressed
here is General voter registration and
the voter registration form
and then if you look down further on
lines 19 and 32
uh there's reference to having this
statute apply specifically to the day of
the general election in terms of
same-day registrations
and then the same thing happens really
throughout the bill but if you go to
page five uh it talks about the the
voter registration form
and then if you go to page six
and you look further down on line 23 it
talks about the day of the state general
election
and
it it
begs the question what happens when
there's an election on a state primary
or a town election
is there same day voter registration if
this is specific to general election day
I think it creates a lot of confusion
and certainly we want voters to be able
to register on the day of any statutory
election not just state general election
day
the other item that I would just briefly
address is that trying to find
equilibrium in the definition of
domicile and residents and how it
applies to elections
has had a pretty shaky past over the
last decade
and with with a court opinion advisory
opinion and and the change of some
statutes I think we've kind of hit
a sweet spot in terms of how it really
Consolidated the definition of domicile
and residence so that it means the same
thing in terms of our election laws
um there was a question about what does
temporary absence mean
basically what that means is that
you do not lose your domicile once it
has been established until you
re-establish a domicile in some other
location
so if you are a resident of New
Hampshire and you're a registered voter
here
and you go to school for example and
you're going to be a student for four
years in some other state
that would be considered a temporary
absence in fact in that instance a
student has the choice of retaining
their residence in the state that they
lived in before they went to school or
in the community that they are living in
while they are attending school that's a
choice that the student gets to make
another example might be a construction
worker
that you know is from New Hampshire for
example and there's a big project going
on in the state of Texas that's the
person is going to be there for six or
seven months while they're working on
the job they don't lose their domicile
in New Hampshire because they've been
away for more than six months of the
year
you heard other examples you know a
person that's serving on the high seas
for long periods of time a person in the
military there is no durational
requirement as long as that voter does
not establish a domicile in some other
location
um
there may have been other questions I'm
happy to answer them Mr chairman but I
think that I'll just stop my testimony
there and
we have questions from the committee
uh yes representative Lane
and
joining other ones do you need that
Authority in a statute or is that
something you already have the authority
to do just under your general regulatory
powers
I believe we already have the authority
to do that we did
participate in the Kansas cross check
program that program is now defunct as
it no longer exists there is another
program that I'm sure you've all heard
of called Eric
um you know there are a lot more
conditions to belong to that program
than the Kansas cross check program
I am not aware of another
program that currently exists although I
know that there are states talking about
forming another program
certainly I'd be really interested in
seeing New Hampshire participate either
as a group or individually with our
surrounding New England states just so
that we can share information
we do share information
not on a entire checklist level or
database level but individual Town
clerks when they become aware of a voter
moving to a different state
will notify you know they share
notifications of when well if somebody
registers from out of state in a town
then our clerks are proactive among our
sister States in New England with
sending notifications out that you know
this person has registered to vote in
such and such a town that the further
away from New England that you get the
less likely that is to happen
and so there certainly is a benefit to
doing these multi-state
projects But to answer your question I
don't think my office needs the
authority to participate in that I think
that we could we could do it
um I had one um you brought up in your
testimony and this has kind of always
baffled me or I don't know baffled
confuse me so
why is it that well let's talk about
students attending a four-year
University right because the going to
Texas for six months or being deployed
and all that stuff four years is a long
time that's four years is a long time so
what is it is there court cases that
have established that college students
are special their effect it sounds to me
like they're super voters right I get to
pick where I get to vote but if they're
attending a four-year University in New
Hampshire they're spending the majority
of their time in New Hampshire for an
extended period of time it's four years
right they're sleeping here ostensibly
um conversely a person an in-state
student who attends an out-of-state
school for four years is sleeping in
another state for four years right going
and spending the majority of time in
that Community for four years what make
like I I don't get to do that right so
like my parents live in Galveston
um much what much nicer weather there
this time of year
um I don't get to say oh I go to
Galveston once every year so like I get
to vote in Texas now like what makes
them special why can't I do that because
is a four year period it's not an
indefinite period of time like that's an
extended period of time so like what
makes them special well there are court
cases supported by Statute and New
Hampshire has a statute as well that
gives
students the the choice of claiming
where their domicile is
and they can be considered absent
you know from their
place of domicile while they're going to
college or if they're engaged in the
community and and decide to make that
their residence and and in effect their
domicile they have the uh the
opportunity to
register to vote in the community that
they're living in while they go to
college
when someone does that however they are
claiming that they are a resident
domiciled in the state of New Hampshire
for example
um and they're subject to all the laws
of the State of New Hampshire that apply
to Residents and I believe the same is
true in other states around the country
any questions were asked my follow-up
yes representative Brennan
thank you Mr chair thank you take my
question
if someone were to establish a domicile
in New Hampshire
and my understanding it correctly that
if they were to attempt to vote
somewhere else
that there there is a penalty for that
and they would have to sign something to
establish their domicile here that
acknowledges that they understand it is
a crime to vote in more than one place
uh that information may be on the voter
registration form I mean it is a crime
to vote in more than one
location
in the same election
somebody could be registered uh to vote
in New Hampshire uh and participate in
uh let's say the town elections coming
up in March
but their circumstance may change after
that and they may move to a different
state and participate in in a
presidential primary
in some other location
there's there is nothing wrong with that
scenario because the person has
established their domicile in a
different place they're not voting in
the same election more than once
and their name may appear on two
different checklists for a period of
time until uh you know that that
information catches up and and the
checklist is corrected
but that would not be a violation of a
statute
about of course if the if there were an
amendment to this
um bill that addresses your concerns
about the
uh day of estate general election
is this a bill that you would support
given that you
support a repeal of sb3's
unconstitutional language
I would support cleaning up the sb3
language in a statute
I'm concerned about the section that you
just mentioned about you know making it
apply just to the day of the general
election to the extent that there are
Provisions in here that
um
the change the the definition of
domicile or residency I think that just
pushes us back into turmoil
and I would not want to see that happen
and in terms of uh you know
participating in some type of a
uh you know I'll call it some type of a
cross-check program comparing checklists
uh but I certainly would support
something like that but again I don't
think that the office needs
representative Howard thank you Mr chair
uh thank you Mr secretary for uh taking
my question uh so when we're looking at
people who are currently living in
nursing homes uh would you recommend
that they vote at their current
Residence at that nursing home or uh
where there are originally domiciled
before uh taking up residency there
nursing home is another category where
the voter has a choice
if a a voter going into an elder care
facility
can continue to vote from the location
that they came from even if family sells
their house and you know that person in
their mind May believe that they're
going back uh at some point even though
you know that's not a practical outcome
however they also have the opportunity
of claiming domicile
from the location of the nursing
facility and so they could vote from
that location but once they do that they
lose their domicile from the place that
they came from
any other questions I I could do this
all day I find this stuff fascinating so
I'm gonna stop but
um any other questions
all right thank you secretary Scanlon
thank you um can we get the blue sheet
I assume no one else here wants to speak
on this we're gonna get like a 25 minute
thank you representative
okay
[Music]
um
all right so we had uh four people sign
up in total three in favor one opposed
um and with that I will uh close the
hearing on hb40 we will be in uh the
committee will stand in recess until 11
A.M today which which point we will
welcome back
we will open the executive session on
House Bill 482 representative Bohm is
recognized for a motion
I make a motion to itl 482. was there a
would you like to speak stream motion
yes does Bill
it's completely goes overboard on what's
needed the accountability for example in
an election is the number of ballots
versus the number of people that voted
the ballots themselves don't have to be
mocked or anything I mean and then the
argument about
There Was X number of unreturned or
uncounted absentee ballots yeah people
didn't send them in
or they got late they got it in late the
point is as long as the number of
absentee ballots received equals the
number of absentee ballots voted it's a
simple counting system so most of this
stuff in this bill is is completely not
necessary I mean the accounting is
equal to
and when we do the some that already
doing it the
um electronic when you come in you're
there and then the accounting is easy
but if the number of people that counted
the ballots I mean at the machines that
counted the balance equal the number of
people voted that's all the
accountability we really need so thank
you
okay the motion is inexperienced to
legislate on House Bill 482 the clerk
will call the roll representative Berry
yes
representative Prudhomme O'Brien yes
representative Bohm
representative qualey yes
representative inkerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wood yes
representative lean yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Smith
yes
does anyone want to move consent move
consent any objection
yep representative phone will do the
report
remember he has to write the mail order
I don't care who does it as long as I
get it today
we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 502 representative Barry is
recognized for emotion uh yes I moved
that house bill 502 be inexpedient to
legislate
representative Berry moves in expedient
would you like to speak to your motion
we could do it now or we can do it on
the OTP
um
this is a major step backwards
um there were things in the bill that
weren't brought up in committee the
first and foremost was out to bring in
this it brings back the religious
affidavit
um so
before I believe we removed that uh two
years ago on a separate bill I I want to
say it had bipartisan support I could be
wrong about that so don't pull me to
that but what this bill would do is he
would re-establish a ludicrous system of
voter registration
so let's explain what this bill would do
this bill would mean that any person
could walk into any polling location
present nothing
and then be given a ballot nothing so
not a driver's license not a piece of
mail not a student ID they literally
would walk into the polling place with
nothing not be on the polls register to
vote and be handed a ballot
and then it brings back the religious
waiver which we got rid of the religious
waiver says that a person may sign in a
religious waiver affidavit if according
to their religion they may not have
their photo taken so even before this we
removed that so that if somebody who
walked in on the polls with nothing they
at least had to have their photo taken
but this repeals that so now they can
say according to my religion I don't
want my photo taken
um and they won't even have to have
their photo taken anymore
there when we did that when we removed
that waiver the first time somebody said
oh well there's somebody's going to sue
well people sue for over election law
almost every time anyways but they never
found anybody with standing they
couldn't find a single person in the
state of New Hampshire that says it's
against my religion to be photographed
because it's not realistic you can't
leave your house without being on
somebody's ring camera there's no way
you're going to drive to the polls
without being on somebody's dash camera
it's it's a ludicrous proposition that
they hold this value set that they don't
believe that they have to have they can
have their photo taken because they
really wouldn't be able to leave the
house that's just unfortunately it's
today's society I'm a privacy person by
the way I'm one of the people that keeps
a little uh keeps the little uh sticky
note on top of the camera on their
laptop like I get it I don't want my
photo taken either but we can't have a
system where you show up to the polls on
Election Day with nothing
um when we pass SB 418 with provisional
ballots I was the one who I caught a lot
of flack for this I'm the one who
watered it down it originally applied to
everybody showing up to the polls on
election day without an ID and I said
well that's that's a big step so we
curtailed it to only people who are
registering on Election Day so we're not
talking about you know 90 of Voters
we're talking about the 10 of the
register on Election Day and the tiny
subset inside of that which I believe
was less than 600 people who bring
nothing to the polls so voter ID as a
whole is very popular in New Hampshire
it holds over 70 popularity it holds
over 50 popularity with Democrats
according to UNH polling it's a very
popular thing
no one here is trying to restrict access
to the ballot no one here is trying to
stop uh you A Kava ballots military
voters from voting SB 418 was brought
forward by a veteran it was passed in
this committee on a motion made by a
veteran if you have you okava concerns
move the primary date move the primary
date this year for 2024 the primary it
wouldn't even be a problem I believe
there's like 53 or 56 days in between
the primary and the general this bill is
not an attack on Military voters it's a
when they when they lob that it's
offensive I'm the son of a military
veteran from Vietnam he's got a bronze
star and my brother's a veteran no one
who voted for this the first time was
attacking veterans all of these are just
red herring distractions
we have to know who's voting in our
elections yes people have a right to
vote in elections I am a Republican and
I hold the unpopular opinion amongst my
party that college students who move
here and go to UNH have a right to vote
here I hold that opinion I get a lot of
flack for it
but I don't understand why we hold
college students up like somehow the
people who are getting four-year degrees
are not smart enough to bring an ID to
the polls like these are people that we
have selected and said you're some of
the brightest in our society yet you
can't remember to bring an ID to the
polls when you're registering to vote
for the first time it's ludicrous it's a
huge step back I get it that there will
be implementation issues with this it's
a bold new thing but we have to find a
way to figure out who's actually
registering to vote you have a right to
vote in the election the voters also
have a right to know who is voting in
their elections so I urge this committee
Ito
is that a boom yeah thank you yeah did I
counted last night or yesterday there
are 56 days between the primary and the
election in 2024. you got to pull that
mic a Little Closer
so that that is not a problem so that's
11 days before and also how many
towns and whatnot would require that
the balance not be printed
at 55 days before I mean be a very small
number because it's the if the number of
affidavit ballots does not
is lower than the number of differences
in in the votes
what difference does it make yeah the
balance will still be pulled but it's
not going to change the outcome so on
those
few yes those may be a few towns maybe
ten I mean may have to wait until
50 days I mean 52 days 53 days before
their ballot
is is can be printed but that's still
less than the 45 days by the government
and yes we have to and we will move the
so about that move in the primary thing
that is not the subject of the bill so
let's keep off of that further
discretion on the bill
foreign
thank you Mr chairman uh so I have a
number of issues with HP 502 uh and to
speak to representative Barry's point
about college students potentially uh
forgetting things on Election Day uh one
of the biggest issues uh that college
students come across is they don't
necessarily remember to bring their
birth certificate or their passport with
them and once you get down uh into the
university it can be something where you
might not necessarily remember to bring
that with you the next time that you go
back uh and with a lot of these people
being 18 and voting for the first time
they might not necessarily know the
process and uh may end up forgetting
things and why they need the affidavit
giving them an extra week to bring in uh
that information might not necessarily
be enough if they live all the way if
they're from uh Arizona per instance uh
they might not necessarily have time to
get that information in those documents
back to New Hampshire
and we need to think about how that
impacts them uh we also have to face the
fact that we have not changed the
primary date and that SB 418 was passed
as an unconstitutional bill uh that all
considered is why we should not move
forward and vote down this Bill thank
you
further discussion on the bill
oh representative blame
um I just want to Echo representative
Howard's statements I also wanted to
bring to light that RSA 659 131c which
is the bill that this would override and
get rid of has other constitutional
problems with it which we heard about in
the testimony
also there's
um there it is not a secret ballot it is
marked by the moderator so there's no
longer a secret ballot which I think is
a huge violation of just tradition and
it may well be a constitutional
violation I don't know I'm not a
constitutional lawyer
um the fact that the ballot is marked by
the moderator is a violation of RSA
65616 which was brought forward uh to
the attention of this committee when it
heard it last year but was ignored
um the the other thing that was asked
that the bill be put to and again an
opinion from either the AG's office when
it was in the Senate the AG's office or
from the Supreme Court but
um the um the Senate Republicans decided
they did not want to do that so I just
wanted to put that out there that those
were other issues that were confronting
it and as representative Howard
mentioned we're dealing with the
primary as it stands now and yes we have
56 days this year but what happens when
you have recounts and what happens uh
when you don't have 56 days
there's a discussion on the bill
representative Barry addressed a couple
things here um so the recount issue the
recount issue is in play irregardless We
Are One Statewide recount away from not
meeting you okava in 2016
um then state representative edelblue
lost to then executive counselor Chris
sununu by less than a thousand votes he
would have been well in his rights to
request a Statewide primary recount and
we would have not made you okaba so if
we're going to use that as a reason to
vote for this bill you got to fix a
whole lot of other things too as to the
secret ballot your ballot is only
revealed if you do not meet the
requirements to to be a registered voter
so somebody whose ballot is pulled out
and the number has changed and their
vote revealed should not have had their
ballot in their otherwise they didn't
prove who they were that they were who
they said they were when they registered
they were not a qualified voter
underneath New Hampshire statutes so
they are not afforded those protections
because their ballot should have never
further discussion on the bill
representative quilly
thank you Mr chairman I heard a
reference in a comment just now to birth
certificates and passports it's my
recollection that the law currently
makes no reference to proof of
citizenship it's merely proof of
identity
so passports and birth certificates
don't enter into any possibility of
representative Muirhead
said to to qualify to vote my
understanding is one needs to prove
identity age residence and citizenship
um
and that citizenship is attested to when
registers Often by affidavit if one
registers more than 30 days before an
election
and uh and and uh and if this bill does
not address citizenship and does not
require any proof of citizenship I think
we need to enter that into the
legislative record explicitly
foreign
okay
the motion is an experience to legislate
on House Bill 502. the clerk will call
the roll
representative Barry yes
representative prunoma Brian yes
representative Bohm yeah
representative qualey yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary
representative wood
yes
representative Lane no
representative Ward
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet no
representative Murad
representative Bay no
representative Brennan no
representative Grill no
representative Howard no
representative Palmer no
and representative Smith
yes
representative Howard I'd like to motion
and I think debate was pretty thorough
so
ready to call the roll
and this is on ought to pass
um representative prudhoma Brian no
representative Bohm no
Representative qualey no
representative Ankerberg no
representative Burnham no
representative Kennedy
representative weary
representative wood no
representative lean yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet
yes
representative Murad
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
and representative Smith no
is another 10 to 10
. this bill will go on the house
and we'll need reports from
so did everybody get the let me end that
um did everybody get the committee
report template that I sent
okay yeah so in a case like this
in the statement of intent portion
that's where you put the motion you
support and why and I'll merge the two
hey representation
uh in a similar vein I have not uh
submitted the report for HP 508 uh
because I would actually like to move
so five 508 you were supposed to write
the report yes
and I missed that you did not do that
that will never ever happen again
committee report so it's like I guess
I'll just State at this clearly when
committee reports are due the day
that we do the executive session I
simply will not accept them after that
if necessary I'll write them myself put
my name on it and that's how that's
um so I I have a motion I I do I have a
moment like seriously never ever ever
pull a move like that again okay
go on uh well as the the clerk had
clarified that this is a just State your
motion okay I motion to uh reconsider HP
and debate on a reconsideration motion
is only what the new information is what
has changed we do not debate the actual
bill itself
yep so uh for hb508 uh we actually have
10 supporters here today uh willing to
vote on this bill of course during the
initial vote for HP 508 it was killed
11-9 uh this bill should have its
opportunity on the house floor to be
okay and at 11 9
it will be heard on the house floor and
Barry uh yes I will be voting against
the motion to reconsider for the reason
you just stated Mr chair which is this
bill will be heard on the house floor
um we've already had our debate we've
already had our vote it's time to move
on
further discussion on the motion to
reconsider
clerk call the roll please
representative Berry no
representative purdom O'Brien no
representative Bohm no
Representative qualey no
representative Ankerberg no
representative Burnham no
representative Kennedy no
representative weary no representative
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative weirhead
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
and representative Smith
no
open the executive session on House Bill
599 representative wood is recognized
for a motion
thank you Mr chair I move HB 599 to the
floor as itl
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you uh while I share a lot of
the uh questions that were brought up by
representative panic and the bill
supporters about the 2020 and the 2022
election I'm concerned with the scope of
the bill and the undefined portions of
the bill
uh section four in particular the
authorization of an unidentified auditor
developing a process to determine and
involving 15 towns and for restless
audits brings up much concerns on my pot
especially when compared to the time and
money spent on the Wyndham audit which
had a very narrow focus a much narrower
than the no Focus right that it has
right now so with these concerns I move
HB 599 as an inexperience to legislate
okay
the motion is an expedient to legislate
on House Bill 599 clerk will call the
representative prudomo Brian yes
representative Bohm yes
representative qualey yes
representative inkerberg yes
representative Burnham
no
representative weary
representative wood yes
representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
and representative Smith yes
objection consent um I moved to consent
calendar Mr chairman
what's up
make a motion of the consent calendar is
there any objection to consent
which I would imagine was already
written
yes Mr Mr chair well done
you know a lot of people do that if they
know they're going to make the motion
that day they just bring it with them
and don't have to have quality time with
you want to do a Minority Report
no no minority reports well that's up to
you
thanks
open the executive session on House Bill
259 representative ackerberg is
recognized for a motion thank you Mr
chairman I move itl on House Bill 259.
and is there a second
you may set a record for most seconds in
a session least reports would you like
to would you like to speak to your
motion no okie dokie
further discussion on the bill
I just would I we understand and
appreciate that this uh bill came from a
good place and is well intended and we
would urge the sponsor to work with the
Secretary of State's office
um to perhaps work on a committee and
work with him to enact this and and or
to put this forward in a different
manner so thank you
further discussion on the bill
emotionalism expedient to legislate on
House Bill 259 the clerk will call the
role representative Berry
yes
representative Prudhomme O'Brien yes
representative Bohm yeah
representative qualey yes
representative inkerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary
representative wood yes
representative lean
yes representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Moorhead
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
and representative Smith yes
22-0
and the Motions adopted and since it's
unanimous I'll assume there's no
objection to consent
we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 395 which will now be
recessed to which I'm to be determined
but it will be noticed at least a couple
of weeks out in the house calendar
executive session is in recess
yep go back to public hearings at one
o'clock
okay we'll start the public hearing on
House Bill 405 and like to ask the
the sponsor representative panic
but please
thank you chairman and members of the
committee
um and allow me to present
introduce house bill 405.
um
this bill creates an in-state tuition
requirement for students of higher
learning learning institutes to be
eligible for voter registration
it's a very large population
that does voting
um
New Hampshire is a wonderful state for
learning we embrace the college students
that attend our 41 colleges and
universities
many may not know but New Hampshire has
14 public and 27 private higher
education institutions
in 2022 our colleges offered more than a
hundred and one thousand five hundred
programs to more than a hundred and
90 000 students 48 000 students took
classes online which means 142
000 students attended classes in person
at universities in New Hampshire
this is amazing uh New Hampshire ranks
number one in the country for college
students as a percent of the overall
population
at over 10 and a half percent of the
whole population more than half of the
students come to New Hampshire from
other states and countries
as this group is 90 is the 99 voting age
um and with such a large number they
have a huge influence on our elections
we want to encourage our young people to
vote and this is a time of a life
we're learning to participate in the
election process is foundational and
important
at the same time we also want the
elections to be the reflection
of those who reside in New Hampshire
towns and who ultimately be the
consequences of the election results
today the university system of New
Hampshire has 18
000 out of
out-of-state students
in our universities and colleges
in the 2022 midterm elections this
out-of-state group represented over 11
of all votes cast for candidates
these students if voting in New
Hampshire elections could determine the
election outcomes and the tension points
must be balanced to encourage voting
while not preventing the
disenfranchisement of New Hampshire
voices
one method to address this issue is a
simple approach
with the help of a college system
the New Hampshire college system has a
clear outline for qualifying for
discounted tuition for in-state students
while also identifying those students
who are domiciled in other states or
countries using this distinction this
bill would use the students in-state
tuition bill at the time of registration
to qualify as a New Hampshire voter the
secretary of state would be supplied a
list of college students eligible to
vote in New Hampshire from the
University system students who are from
other states would participate in their
home state elections through their
foreign
if you have any questions I'd be happy
to answer them if I can
thank you any questions yes
representative Howard thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you for uh sharing
your thoughts today uh my question uh
revolves around the fact that uh I guess
more of a hypothetical I'm a student
currently at the University of New
Hampshire in Durham I've resided in the
town of Stratford for my entire life uh
and just to kind of read off from the
bill here I qualify for in-state tuition
would this mean that I'd have to provide
a copy of my tuition bill when I go to
the Stratford Town Hall not if you're an
in-state okay I think there was a um I
think there was a an error on this bill
when it was uh proposed this should be
asking just for out-of-state students to
provide
okay proof of where they're out of state
residents
so this bill has been drafted up
erroneously I just caught this the other
day
yeah it says in-state voters and the
community college system shall provide a
student list of eligible in-states
voters to the Secretary of State it
should say ineligible
in-state students
we have a typo here that I just caught
so that changes the meaning of the bill
yeah follow up
uh so since uh students would need to be
providing a copy of their tuition would
dependent students in the case of the
students is still support that are
supported by their parents in a drama
style is the family home with the
parents in New Hampshire proof provided
to the universities a notarized letter
from the parents describing the domicile
including statement from the town clerk
or town register indicating parents
voter registration copies of the student
federal income tax return as well as
that portion of parents federal income
tax returns that list dependence claim
for the most of the recent years
and copy of all support or custody
decrees appropriate sections of wills
and trust being used to support the
application
and a copy of or a copy of any New
Hampshire driver's license or vehicle
registration
the colleges do have you know they they
they they have a tuition for rate for
in-state students and out-of-state
students so if we can get that out of
State student identified and given that
to our secretary of state that's a block
of Voters that we can ensure that
they're going to vote where they're
appropriately supposed to be voting and
they have to do mail if they have to do
absentee voting for another state that's
you know in their home state that's okay
but we're trying to predict protect you
know our vote here
thank you anybody else did I answer any
questions yes representative
thank you Mr chair
um and thank you representative
um what your bill only covers uh state
universities and state what about all
my understanding is this is supposed to
cover all the universities
uh in-state in-state tuition
my understanding is this is covering all
the universities in New Hampshire in the
the thing is that Saint anselms and
Dartmouth schools like that do not have
in-state they're not State institutions
they don't differentiate between New
Hampshire residents and those outside
they must have some type of registration
where the shows where the student
resides
any further questions
well thank you representative all right
thank you
now I call
I have some written testimonies so Excel
handed around the table uh
foreign
thank you I'm representative Timothy
Horrigan from Stratford County District
10 not to be confused with James
Horrigan or Michael Harrington who are
also from Stratford County
um
so I was
so I've got some written testimony here
which I think I emailed to you I also
put it on the website and I'm passing
hard copies around
um
and um that's like a belted suspenders
and second belt approach um
and uh well first of all I was talking
this morning about residents and
domiciles I think some of what you heard
about residents they're trying to
redefine residents from what it actually
means legally so uh
so what I said and I refer to that here
my written testimony actually which is a
typically
live on their campus or nearby for 9 to
12 months out of the year they're
physically present in the community and
that's really enough right there to
establish residents in domicile they
work there and pay taxes and Community
the Census Bureau counts them at their
on or off campus residence and I speak
from personal experience because I used
to work for I worked on two to San Diego
census for the Census Bureau in fact
one of the major post-census activities
is uh
tracking down hundreds of thousands of
duplicate entries for students who uh
either fill out a question form or gets
counted on campus but you also get
counted at their parents house and as
the entry at the parents house which is
actually the duplicate record that needs
to be removed not the one at the on
campus or off-campus residence and um
the RSA that this would amend is RSA 654
uh one Roman numeral one
a and that actually flips the meaning of
the existing law totally on its head I
was actually a member of House election
law my first term back in 2009
uh when that RSA was 64
654 colon 1 Roman numeral 1A was added
by hb614 and that was a long time ago
but I remember that hearing vividly uh
and the purpose of the bill is actually
to affirm students voting rights as
established by the previous sub-chapters
the RSA which you would not be surprised
I tell you that which that was pretty
obvious RSA 654 colon 1 Roman numeral
one and many other state and federal
laws and
we had very interesting hearing way back
then and there's even one gentleman
who'd ran Plymouth and lost because he
didn't do a good job of get getting the
students to vote for him he wanted us to
exclude the students because he felt he
should have rightfully won and that's
not how the system works so if you have
students or any other group of Music the
thing to do is to try to appeal to them
try to get them to vote for you
um
there were two constitutional law cases
at least one of which was specifically
mentioned this morning the other Bill
neuberger versus Peterson that was the
uh Dartmouth student from Hawaii who
um
anyway he was either unable or unwilling
to uh vote back home the version of
Story I Heard which was from Secretary
of State gardeners that his parents had
died so he wasn't eligible to vote in
Hawaii but in any case
he wasn't going back to Hawaii and he
probably wasn't going to hand over but
he wanted to vote in Hanover and then
the Federal Court ruled that he he had
every right to do so there's also Sims
versus U.S
and um Sims was a county I think he was
a County Registrar in a Suburban county
of Houston which is predominantly white
but has a famous black uh historically
back college or university Prairie View
and he was trying to prevent the Prairie
View students from voting and whether
he's doing that for racial reasons just
for anti-student voting reasons isn't
really relevant the uh although that did
make the case that much more
controversial but so that clearly
established way back near I graduated
from college that students have the
right to vote in the place where they
live when they're going to college and
um
aside from being constitutional bill is
a bad idea I'll mention one well one
basic one voting is a good habit so is
being involved with your local community
in other ways
college is where young adults
establish the habits of their future
life both good and bad and this bill
seems to be an expressly designed well I
guess it was she said the prime sponsors
said so this guy deserves college
students from developing the habits of
voting and Civic involvement although
she did mention
they could put absentee and Alicia thank
you for not applying what we usually
hear in these debates
the adverb simply devoting by absentee
voting absentee is not simple and most
of the bills relate to absentee voting
and designed to make it even less simple
so absentee voting I mean it's lots of
people do it it's not
that complicated but it's not exactly
like simple and
the methodology is fatally flawed as we
found out well really doing the
questions he ignores the fact it
um well first of all else in state
tuition it's based primarily in where
you lived before you enrolled in college
although there actually are some some
exceptions
like to certain programs at state
universities where you can get his state
tuition even though your so-called
out-of-state student
um there's probably actually and there
is the Assumption hidden behind this
bill that every college student
you know lives in their childhood home
to their 18 they immediately head off to
college and then immediately only stay
in the college town for four years and
then they go back home or whatever so
that's not how
most uh students institutions of higher
education live their lives these days
and even they did
moving moving to a community to attend a
College University there is as good a
reason as any to move to that community
so there's nothing illegitimate about
that um
and so and there's anyway so it's uh and
see not even all that uncommon for a
student to move to a college town you
know establish a domicile
and then later decides of Rome to
college and actually that's a practical
matter unless they're living in an
on-campus residence you really have
checklists have no really no way of like
figuring out where the person actually
is a student or not you know like we do
have
I mean some college towns we do have
some primarily even if you live in one
of those uh student housing complexes
that they have on the outskirts of uh
Durham not everyone
those complexes is necessarily a student
and uh
and there probably are some and there
are some people who live in dormitories
who are like older people sometimes even
with families and stuff who aren't
necessarily students there's a few cases
of that
and um as we heard and we heard actually
it's now been proven we the number we
were just told by the prime sponsors
there's 27 private institutions and 14
um
public institutions so that my math that
means it's almost a two to one ratio
private to public and even if we got the
numbers backwards that's one-third is
still a significant percentage so
and there is no in-state tuition at a
private private institution so what do
you do about those um
so I don't really know what
documentation we expected when students
at private colleges try to register to
vote say if you're at Dartmouth or Saint
anthems even if you're living in the
dorm you know what
as written there's nothing to say what
sort of a documentation those people
need
anyways there's also some students
who live in New Hampshire during the
school year or year round but whose main
occupation is going to school in another
state
um
we even have uh we even have one yet
famous university here in New Hampshire
whose campus spills over across the
state lines the Dartmouth College campus
it's mostly on the east side of the
Connecticut River in Hampton but
part of the campus is on the west side
of the Connecticut River on the far side
of the Ledyard Bridge or the near side
depending whether you're from Vermont to
New Hampshire so
that's a whole other complication like
which which state
you know Dartmouth College is physically
located in both states and
I guess that's primarily the Vermont's
assemblies problem not ours so that's
like some other election law committee
to worry about so
and um
something that wasn't really hasn't
really been mentioned yet I've heard in
other bills and this topic is uh the
out-of-state tuition
it's twice the in-state tuition that UNH
and most of the other state schools so
it's a
there's like uh because sometimes I've
heard some
at other debates on summer bills I heard
like well these kids are playing out of
state tuition you know they shouldn't be
able to vote almost implications almost
out of state tuition such a great
privilege that like yes you know asking
to be allowed to vote on top of it which
is a basic constitutional right is for
some people too much but it's
you know it's twice as much as the
in-state tuition I'm not necessarily
there's good reasons for that and um UNH
and the other state schools they offer
some very excellent programs it's not
necessarily uh
it's not necessarily a bad deal for the
out-of-stage students but they are you
know getting over steel then the
in-state students so uh
if by anything if anything maybe
we should have the uh
maybe we should restricted the
out-of-state students because they're
paying like twice as much in in in uh
tuition than the in-state students so
yeah so anyway so this this is a uh
this bill is a bad idea it's also
unconstitutional those are two good and
um those are two good reasons itl that I
know the prime sponsor
notice some drafting errors
but I I think the basic idea in my
opinion it's such a bad idea I don't
think you can fix it so the best thing
that best thing to do is is uh is
finding any expedient to legislate and
um I'm sure we'll see
and we'll probably see similar
legislation in the future but this one
this one I think is fatally flawed so I
don't think I don't think it's worth
your time to fix it you've got a lot of
other legislation to work on so
um I guess I'm kind of leaning against a
build as you probably discovered so if
anybody wants to ask answer ask me any
questions I'll try to answer
is there any questions representative
Moorhead thank you um I I wanted to
address the uh and ask you about the the
possibility that Dartmouth College might
might spill over into the
state of the the neighboring state that
would go unnamed to the west of the
Connecticut River
um it may own some land over there but
but there are no dormitories no no
Dartmouth students live okay over there
and I just wonder if you would join me
uh in opposing a a movement that I've in
underground movement rumored to be led
by an esteemed representative from New
Hampshire's Queen City to gift Hanover
to the state of Vermont and if if that
movement gains any momentum I hope
you'll help me I would support the post
oh I mean no I I no I would oppose it I
would support your position
Hanover west by the way the first
capital of the Republic of Vermont which
included a large portion of what's now
New Hampshire so uh
we should keep Hanover uh Hanover uh in
New Hampshire we don't want to give it
back to Vermont just one of our finest
communities and can we stay with the
bill please there are there are quite a
few students yeah
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Horgan for your testimony
today
um so does enrollment or attendance at a
school established
the domicile or the residents
it's
it's uh more what I was talking about is
more like where you're living while
attending classes because uh well we're
talking about Dartmouth for example
there's a number of Dartmouth students
who rent apartments and uh especially in
Norwich or White River Junction
um
they would even though they're attending
classes in Vermont even though there are
a couple of classroom buildings in
Norwich they're going to school in New
Hampshire so they
for that purpose it would be residents
of Vermont but they so that but that's
aren't as many cases the other way but
uh they're probably a few edge cases of
people commuting
moving
moving from somewhere else to New
Hampshire and then commuting across the
community across the state line to
another state and of course you also
have students who are in low residency
programs or online programs too so it's
at least in my view what I have in mind
is where you're where you're living
where you're spending uh spending your
time while you're going through while
you're attending the educational
Institution
okay so I don't know if that answers it
or not but thank you thank you
any more questions
I now call
Mr Tom Cronin
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Tom Cronin uh
and I am the director of government
relations for the University system uh
we're here today in opposition to House
Bill 405 uh in our opinion because it
impractically puts our institutions in
between our students and their right to
vote uh we essentially have two main
concerns with the bill first is it's
attempting to link a student's right to
vote under RSA 651 uh colon 1 1A with
resident tuition
under current law state statute gives
our Board of Trustees the authority to
set resident tuition rates for uh
in-state and out-of-state students
essentially right now the out-of-state
tuition rate is a function of two main
components first you have to prove that
you've lived in the state for a year or
longer and second you have to prove that
you have lived in the state for some
purpose other than education so
essentially you couldn't come back as a
junior for example and say I've lived
here for two years because your main
purpose is education you'd have to show
some other connection to the state in
order to
gain access to in-state tuition rates
the issue here becomes by linking the
two of those together the bill
essentially creates a one-year plus
residency requirement for college
students that doesn't exist for anybody
else in the state of New Hampshire when
it comes to vote as this committee well
knows the state does not have a
residency requirement so by linking
in-state tuition which requires at least
one year of residency with your right to
vote you've created that for one class
of Citizen uh I'd also second comments
have been made so far the private
institutions in our state do not have
in-state tuition rates so students would
not have a way to show in-state tuition
while registering to vote so essentially
this creates a second class of Citizen
only for students at the public
universities and colleges
our second concern uh deals with parts
essentially two and three of the bill
two for us three for our colleagues at
the community college system uh whereby
the university system will be required
to provide a list of eligible in-state
voters to the Secretary of State the way
this is written really we have two
questions uh because it's tacked on to
the section on identification cards it's
unclear to us if we would actually be
required to provide a list of eligible
in-state voters for every student in the
state which is what the requirement for
identification cards is or would just be
required for our students uh and second
the university system quite frankly is
not the organization in the state that
deals with voter eligibility that is the
town clerks the secretary of state folks
you all know far better we can tell you
uh pieces of it but we are not going to
judge are you a citizen uh or does your
age all these other pieces that is for
others to decide as part of this process
so with that I think I'd be happy to
take any questions
thank you any questions yes Mr
representative Howard thank you Mr chair
and uh thank you uh Mr Cronin for coming
today uh so when determining in-state
tuition uh what factors are taken into
account
again the two main ones and uh actually
I think the representative the sponsor
uh was actually into uh the board
guidelines on this but again the two
main things is in order to be eligible
for in-state tuition you have to prove
you've lived here for at least a year
and you have to prove you've been here
for purposes other than education so you
can't just move into the state and say I
would like in-state tuition after having
essentially attended one of our
institutions for a year you have to have
been here for a year and you have to
have shown you are here for some purpose
other than education so again that's our
concern by saying you have to show
you've been here for a year in order to
access in-state tuition you've created
this uh essentially one-year residency
requirement that doesn't exist for
anybody else seeking to register to vote
in the state uh follow up
yeah I I might not have necessarily been
as specific but uh do uh essentially uh
are our parents the ones determining
residency of the individual student uh
before they attend the University yeah
they certainly I mean certainly a
parent's uh place of residence does play
into it particularly for un
um yeah I have a question about
yeah this in general
um
they're voting here they're registering
to vote here they're establishing
domicile here why aren't we giving them
in-state tuition they're saying they're
going to stay here for an indefinite
period of time
are we not are we discriminating against
these um young adults for not giving
them in-state tuition like shouldn't
they get it when they register vote
they're saying they want to be a part of
the state so why we continue to say no
you're an outsider we're going to charge
you more even though you're voting on
our elections sure again the board of
the state RSA gives our Board of
Trustees authority to determine in-state
and out-of-state tuition currently that
is determined really by two factors have
you been here for at least a year uh and
are you here for some purpose other than
education follow-up so so what so the
the boards in their conversations why
did they set it there why didn't they
did they take this into consideration of
this person's voting here so they now
live here you know this person is voting
here they have a New Hampshire driver's
license if they are um they registered
their car here they're according to our
voting laws they're staying here for an
indefinite period of time why did the
board take into consideration why are we
not giving them in-state tuition and
does that do we need to to mandate that
sure so again uh our board has been
given the authority to determine how
they uh how we set in-state tuition
rules lived here for a year some purpose
other than education and I'll say you
know we certainly have students who
approach us on an occasional basis to
say that I've been living in New
Hampshire I you know I moved here from
somewhere else uh you know I live in an
apartment off campus in Durham I live
here now I should be eligible for
in-state tuition but again we have rules
in place that say you need to prove one
year plus have income for some other
purpose
representative Howard thank you uh thank
you Mr chair uh and I guess what would
the financial impact be of those
students receiving in-state tuition
instead of paying out of state yeah and
we've had legislation proposed to do
exactly what representative Berry has
suggested I think in past years to
essentially say to to link it the other
way right so this this attempt is to say
uh you have to show in-state rates in
order to register the other one was you
could show your voter registration as an
in-state requirement we obviously oppose
that as it would be hundreds of millions
of dollars okay thank you
and representative Homer Bryant thank
you Mr chairman
are there any other exceptions made that
students would receive in-state tuition
other than the year
uh residency requirement and the
requirement that they be here for
another purpose is there any other
exception to that any other student that
gets in-state tuition
I'm not going to say there that I that
there isn't I couldn't go find you a
case I will say those are the two pieces
that you really need to you need to
clear that hurdle before your granted
in-state tuition
there are a number of other pieces that
go into that calculation but if you
can't show Beyond those two then that's
representative
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for your
testimony uh do the schools you
represent are they land grant schools uh
the University of New Hampshire is the
land grant and then Keene State and
Plymouth state are the other two
components of the University system so
land grant as I understand it land-grant
schools will grant out-of-state students
in-state tuition if those programs are
not offered in their home state as part
of the compact yes
good example yeah so I'm not sure though
how many of those
I would I would need to go get some
information for you to how many of those
we actually have but
any any any organization that's part of
right those compact programs will offer
those collaborative rights for sure
right I can I can do a little bit on
that at the former member of the New
England Board of higher education that's
one of the things we do it's in the it's
in our budget that we give x amount of
money to the name of the board of higher
education and they determine
in different universities or colleges
across New England for example New
Hampshire does not have a dental school
Maine does and so those are the
agreements that have worked out between
the states with the New England Board of
Hyatt
when I saw representative boam chairing
this committee I know it was all set
after having spent a few years with them
in House Education
any other questions
okay thank you thank you all I need to
run but I'm happy to take questions
afterwards if there are other okay thank
you
okay
hope I get this right Mrs oh miss
whatever to Lisa blasik or Telco blasik
I'm sorry I couldn't read the writing
that's okay it's
philosopher yeah
thank you for allowing me to speak today
Mr chairman
and thank you to committee members for
allowing me to hear my testimony
first of all I want to say that I'm in
support of all students
um and uh all students voices
um but I am here to testify in favor of
this bill and I do believe that students
should not be allowed a dual State
citizenship status
wherever their parents May reside or
where they they may reside should be one
location
our votes are so precious to America
that our government placed it under the
security of the dod then further the
under the homeland security why would we
not protect every single vote in the
state of New Hampshire with the same
precautions and vettings we do as a
driver's license for State of New
Hampshire DMV
if a student must pay out of state
tuition to benefit from the New
Hampshire lawful citizen state tax
contributions as for their Institution
than the same qualification should apply
to their ability to vote on the outcomes
for our elections
our founding fathers had three boxes
when we when creating our country first
was the soapbox which allows us our
right to Rally using our inalienable
rights such as freedom of speech to be
heard today and I support that for our
students as well
the second is The Ballot Box our votes
which are precious to each one of us as
the money that we work so hard to
diligently earn and trustingly place
into bank vaults as we do our votes at
the polls investing into our futures
this is the topic that we're here to
discuss today the third is the ammo box
as a result of the sacrifice and all the
battles won beginning here in Portsmouth
New Hampshire in 1775. thankfully today
we don't need that box because of a
brilliant and brave statesman's
who made clear their intentions for this
country assembled in the American Bill
of Rights white papers their body of
work and consideration that went into
drafting are an incredible Constitution
to ensure that we would have protection
over these rights with a military that
protects our sovereignty and our votes
I am hopeful with our new Congress
that's before us today each of you took
a pledge to defend and protect our
constitution so I implore you
that you monitor the votes actions
speech and public Communications
assiduously of ourselves yourselves and
your fellow Representatives today I know
that lawful citizens such as myself are
watching with baited breath thank you
and God bless America
if anybody have any questions
okay thank you
okay
um Michael O'Brien
you can say you were a lobbyist
thank you Mr chairman to the committee
my name is Michael O'Brien uh with party
strategies here on behalf of America
votes and apologize for the handwriting
my eight-year-old continuously reminds
me that hers is better than mine
um I uh we're here today to post this
bill in a lot of
what we're gonna say has already been
said so I just do want to read though
from the uh UNH page for in-state
tuition a student's residence for
tuition purposes is considered to be
that of their parent unless the student
is emancipated so qualify for
institution status a student or his or
her parents if a dependent must
physically reside in New Hampshire for
12 months so to tie someone's voting
rights and individuals own rights to
their parents obviously is very
problematic
um newburger versus Peterson is
referenced to the 1972 case that gave
students the right to vote in the city
or town in which they go to college
and so for those two reasons alone we
oppose this bill and ask you to Ideal it
I have to take any questions
anybody have any questions
thank you
Al brandak
okay
thank you everybody
my name is Al brendano I'm from
Kensington New Hampshire
um
I think it was Mark Twain once said
the most uncommon sense is common sense
when you I'm in favor strongly in favor
of HB 405
and the reason for it specifically is if
you look back and especially recently
here in New Hampshire New Hampshire is
purple and what does that mean means
that elections can be lost within three
to five percent of the votes and it
doesn't matter what party is in power
right now or not because that can change
in an economic situation or other
so this is about not just voting rights
but it's about secure elections and I
think it's really important that we talk
about students in this case college
students with special privileges and let
me explain
the Attorney General Nicholas Kong yen
in November 2020 New Hampshire college
students temporarily living outside the
state because of covid-19 pandemic can
continue claiming Granite State as a
domicile and are allowed to vote in
November third election the State
Attorney General's office said Wednesday
once a student lawfully established a
domicile in New Hampshire the student
does not lose his domicile due to
Temporary absence
I ask you how long is a temporary
absence
three months six months two years
can you vote in New Hampshire five years
from now I don't know but it's clearly
it's a special privilege
how about domicile and Resident another
special privilege this is from the
Secretary of State's website
and Joint guidance is provided
by the co the consultation with the
Attorney General's office the following
guidance on voter registration is
provided by the Secretary of State
the following guidance on the mode of
vehicle law is provided by the
commissioner of the Department of Safety
the terms Dom missile and Resident are
equivalent
this is a problem and I'll explain later
even though RSA
21-6a and RSA
65641 contain different words this is
them this is from the Department itself
they can convey the same basic concept
when a person makes a toner award in New
Hampshire his or her principal place or
physical presence to the exclusion of
all other places that person has
established a domicile in Residence
think about what we're doing now for
security of voting
once again it doesn't matter what party
is in place
we're changing we're adding we're
increasing security and the word um
domicile and residence
we're giving special privileges
special privileges again this is from
the University of New Hampshire's main
voting website it says and I quote
Additionally the legislative legislature
of New Hampshire did directly give
college students the special privileges
on that does not normally apply to a New
Hampshire citizen from the from the
voting page the web page New Hampshire
election law provides college students
with special privileges that's them not
me saying that when determining where
they register to vote the college
student in New Hampshire may choose as
his voting domicile either the domicile
they held before entering College are a
domicile they established while
attending college
students may only select one
once again the regular citizen doesn't
have this opportunity in New Hampshire
when registering to vote this is from
the website again you need to have
identity some photo ID
such as a valid driver's license or form
of a New Hampshire ID for your
University
domicile your address for voting
purposes you have to be age 18 and
here's the one that gets me U.S citizens
passport birth certificate or
naturalization papers if you do not have
one of these documents you can sign a
document attesting to your citizenship
why is this troubling
who at the Secretary of State at the
Department of Justice
checks this does anybody
of course not
once again New Hampshire is the safest
or the easiest place to vote but are we
the most secure
register to vote okay
I'll close with this
um
how did we get here I think it's really
important that we understand that
HB 1264 in 2018 was passed by the
legislature and signed by the governor
and I believe unconstitutionally in
violation of the Bill of Rights part one
article 11 and part 2 article 30 without
the consent of the people later RSA 21 6
and 216a sponsored by Republicans
unconstitutionally expanded to allow the
expansion of absentee voters granting
resident aliens the right to vote this
once again was a violation of the New
Hampshire constitution in my opinion New
Hampshire Constitution part one
and the Bill of Rights in part two form
of government this is very important the
definition of inhabitant and appears 23
times the term resident appears once in
the form of government
that's
clearly an indication of what the intent
of the law was
in regards to inhabitant there is no
Authority for the legislator to change
voting rights or give special privileges
to resident aliens with or without
altered domicile or resident status
please vote to pass HP 405.
and return back to the New Hampshire
Constitution and correct this Sovereign
violation and voting injustices that's
been placed upon all New Hampshire
thank you Mr chair
thank you
um So based off of what you just said
does that mean that um during the 2020
elections students that were
told to stay home and could not be on
campus were they voting by absentee
ballot from their school they could have
yes they could have been in New Jersey
voting absentee ballot in New Hampshire
maybe voting in New Jersey too we don't
know that the challenge for all of us in
New Hampshire is we make it and the
secretary of state says that you know we
make it the easiest place to vote but is
it the most secure and here's the
challenge with taxpayers that are
funding the bills coming forward with
three to five percent voting margins
think about it in New Hampshire we had
11 contested results last year in 2022.
Senate District 24 is the big one that
hasn't even been resolved yet in far as
uh what happened there it didn't happen
this is that's still on the plate at the
election law committee uh not the
election law committee the ballot law
commission excuse me so my point is we
need to make things a little bit more
secure there's nobody checking these
details the Secretary of State the
Department of Justice nobody checks
there is no check and balance and when
we're the citizens are fronting these
bills coming forward on education and
all other things our say needs to be
more important than in my opinion than
people who aren't here for the end
result
follow-up please
would that also
um
would would overseas New Hampshire
students also be able to vote by
absentee ballot in New Hampshire if
they're students of New Hampshire I
don't know the answer to that but I I
could try to find it for you but I
really don't know I've never studied
that okay thank you thank you
president Barry I'm on a wave okay
okay thank you thank you
hello I am Lee Heath I attend the
University of New Hampshire and I oppose
this bill
I am an out-of-state student from Maine
um I am 17 so I have not yet voted but I
can already see all the ways Laws affect
my life I spend nearly half my life in
New Hampshire
um studying I pay taxes on food when I
go I am part of the workforce I work for
minimum wage so my how much I earn is
determined by votes here I know it's
more than
taxes and my wage determined by votes
and almost every fragment of my life is
determined by some sort of law and if I
don't have a say there's so many rum
there's so much room for abuse to
exploit students who are coming here and
trying to work for New Hampshire and
um these facts alone I believe earn my
right to vote here and
um
because I live my life here I go home to
Maine
not nearly as much as I spend here
also I hear stories of people attempting
to vote with absentee's balance mailing
it in on time and yet it gets lost in
the shuffle removing their say and what
um thank you
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question do you feel that this bill
will put a new burden for students to be
able to vote
yes
um I I I believe it would
make it so they can be abused in the
system can I follow up oh
um
do you think that making it harder for
students to vote makes voting in New
Hampshire more secure
no I think making it harder means less
vote overall a less idea of what people
representative Howard thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh so I I understand that
you're 17 so you haven't spent too much
time at the University system but how
much time have you spent or are you
planning on spending in the state this
year
five days a week I
guess here clubs work
it
okay one more question thank you very
and correct me if I'm wrong no that's
good afternoon and thank you members of
the committee Mr chairman my name is
Alice house I live in Durham New
Hampshire and I oppose house bill 405. I
am a third year at the University of New
Hampshire
three years ago I moved to New Hampshire
to attend UNH and I've grown to really
love this state
being involved in politics here has been
actually one of my major sources of
community
since I became a New Hampshire voter
registering last fall I have really
noticed a change in myself
before I considered my Homestay my home
now I really feel invested in the future
of this state I'm interested in what's
going on here in the in the legislature
building and I really consider this my
home and I'm considering staying out
east specifically New Hampshire after
graduation
uh there are a lot of great things about
the state and there are a lot of ways
that I think it could be even better
um and I think that if you want young
people to stay in New Hampshire
um you need to allow them some say
in its future
if this bill was in effect
um back when I registered to vote I
would not have been able to register to
vote because I'm paying out of state
tuition
and this bill might seem like a
technicality a matter of numbers but to
me it feels like I'm being looked in the
face and told that even though I live
here work here rent property here and
hold Community here that my input should
not matter
I discussed this issue recently last
fall with a mentor that I love and am
very close to
he thinks that out of state students
should not vote here and his arguments
suggested that student voters Were
Somehow less important than other voters
contrary to New Hampshire law
he also talked about students as
temporary when students as a demographic
will always be here
he also talked as if we threaten people
who own property here and have lived
here for a long time but the way I see
it that shouldn't necessarily need to be
true and our goals shouldn't have to be
opposed
then I asked him if he was going to vote
in the election
and he said no
he said he didn't know enough about
politics in New Hampshire specifically
in Durham to vote yeah I said okay
that's fair
but at the time I talked to him he had
had four days or he had four days still
leading up to the election to talk to
people in this community
to learn about
um
to read articles and to go vote
um not to mention he was living in New
Hampshire and had months and months
leading up to this election to do so
and yet he didn't vote I asked him after
the election just to make sure
um meanwhile every student I know got
involved
did their research either sent their
absentee ballot home
or registered in New Hampshire and voted
here
and voted and I think if students are
residents here and are affected by these
laws and we care about this process
enough to get involved that they should
not be excluded from voting
I ask that you please protect this right
by voted voting inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill 405. thank you and I'm
open to questions
any questions
uh yes miss that one representative
Allen thank you Mr chairman uh I'll make
this easy uh easy on you uh how long
have you lived in New Hampshire and how
long do you intend to spend here uh this
year thank you
um
yes so I am in my third year of college
so I began living here fall of 2020.
um and I've just stayed here
um I go home I've gone home twice for a
period of
two months
for one summer two months for another
summer and then come back here and that
is what I've done
thank you I have a question uh okay
representative paper
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my call
do you think that the passing of this
bill will discourage young people from
um I think so and I think
um the reason is that
I've gotten really involved in groups on
campus
um student organizations and such that
um that participate in the political
process and I felt that I've been much
more engaged and much more interested in
that
once I've started voting here right and
so
um I think that a lot of students could
you know keep up with their home state
could send home their ballot but a lot
of students care a certain amount
um but not always enough to listen to
that news every day to you know figure
out what's going on in their home state
whereas I felt very involved here
and I've just cared a lot more about
voting here so I think that um
I think that in some ways it would
discourage students from becoming
civically involved here just because
it's easier to get civically involved
where you live and you're around people
um to discuss with
yes
follow up
um this making it harder for UNH
students to vote
um do you feel that it makes
um the election
um
personally I don't I think that depends
on who you are and what your opinion is
but I think that students are
demographic that are going to be here
um even if not everyone stays that's
going to cycle through and so I don't
believe it's more secure to
um exclude out of state students from
voting
any further yeah I have a question do
you have a New Hampshire ID or a main ID
um I do not have a New Hampshire idea I
have a Wisconsin ID and I'm working on
getting that to New Hampshire ID and
registering my car here okay thank you
every time weary
do you plan on
um so we have a another local elections
coming up in March are you
actively involved in that and are you
looking to vote in that particular
election
yes absolutely and as a follow-up Mr
chairman um are other students in
Dartmouth or in that area or where in
UNH uh doing that same sort of
um activity level and is there I mean
I'm just trying to understand yeah if
it's beyond the presidential elections
or the you know kind of midterm
elections but it's actually extending
down into the local community right
right and and every issue and every
election
um yes
um and the group that I'm with and just
me personally I try to reach out to all
of my friends
um and just let them know that elections
are coming up we do a lot of tabling to
say Hey you know things are happening go
get involved and I've seen
I mean I'm so surprised by everyone I
talk to a lot of people already know
what's going on or would like to learn
more
um so I would say that a lot of students
at least the students that I'm around
which is a lot of students that I'm
interacting with
um day to day are clued in or want to be
included in
um to all the different elections and
not just presidential I mean the one I
was referring to that we did a lot of
work for was the November elections um
which I know are also very important but
all the elections are important and um I
know that I will be voting and
everything that I can
um and I believe a lot of other students
will be too all right thank you thank
you
thank you thank you so much thank you
um any I don't have no more cards
anybody else want to speak if not
representative would you give me the
blue sheet please
405.
thank you for the help
thank you so we have one two three four
four and four against
okay with that I'm closing the hearing
on
House Bill 405 and in a few minutes
179.
foreign
foreign and it's now two o'clock
and open the hearing on House Bill 179
unfortunately I do not see the sponsor
in the room
so
would somebody just want to
open up the bill and we can take
testimony
you don't have to say you're for or
against it because
foreign
okay I'd like to introduce Bill 179 up
for public hearing this bill amends the
definition of elect electioneering to
remove the prohibition against wearing
clothing or paraphernalia that a
reasonable person would believe
explicitly advocates for or against any
candidate political party or measure
being voted
thank you
I now call
don't they fix this last year
it doesn't fix this I continue to be
representative Timothy Horrigan from
Stratford County District 10 and um I
probably actually will be brief this
time um
so I
I
um
so I guess and of course uh the bill
um it's self-explanatory just heard the
whole uh
basically just heard the whole thing
there which is um for many years it's uh
been against well not really against the
law it'd be pretty I don't think
anyone's ever been arrested for this but
you're not supposed to wear
buttons t-shirts hats
Etc which are for against a candidate or
a measure on the ballot into the in the
into the polling place and although
a lot of those do like slip through the
cracks so like unless you have an
especially uh zealous moderator uh
they'll usually just pretend they didn't
see the item an electric boat but I
think
I think it's valuable
um well I'm going to say something which
I got ridiculed for in the different
context a few years ago which was the uh
uh polling place is not a free speech
zone so this is not a Zone where you're
supposed to be electioneering or
campaigning and actually uh they uh
you know they and they they're trying uh
trying to preserve that in this bill but
I think keeping the existing uh
restriction in place I think makes it
makes it clearer you could you will
fewer cases where somebody's will claim
we'll be doing more than just wearing
the article clothing and then claim well
all I was doing was wearing the article
of clothing so you have some of that but
also I think it's a good idea
not to have this stuff in the polling
place it's supposed to be a neutral safe
Zone where you're uh of course that's
probably another unpopular phrase safe
Zone but um
or safe place but uh you were supposed
to cast a balancing count them securely
and um
another thing this is going to do is
going to let you wear your uh
where your buttons your articles of
clothing uh within the 100 mile 100 not
100 mile 100 foot radius of the polling
place and that's uh also a
zone that we'd like to keep clear for
various
various reasons so you probably have
people congregating inside the 100 foot
Zone and that actually
there's a bill that's being heard in
criminal justice and I'm the prime and
only sponsor of and it'll be at the
floor eventually where
um well it's Banning carrying firearms
um in the polling place that's another
constitutional right which is probably
temporary which you have outside the
polling place in the 100 yard radius but
not
unimpeded inside that zone then
one of my Arguments for that's been on
the written testimony of Criminal
Justice is that in case the 100 foot
sign is missing
the gun owner can tell where the zone is
because there will be people gathered
101 feet from the entrance of the
polling place with their signs and their
signs and their paraphernalia so that'll
uh
create more confusion for the unwitting
gun owner who's accidentally wandering
into the polling place uh he won't know
where that hundred foot zone is as
easily as you know if either the sign is
missing or he doesn't see the signs so
that's one more
um I mean that's that's probably
slightly uh that's probably a slightly
uh maybe that's a slightly snarky
observation but I just thought I'd
mention that that is like there will be
additional difficulty of both this bill
and that bill passes uh which
um so I would just urge you to keep keep
the law where way it is I mean it's fine
if somebody accidentally gets through
with their hat or their button or their
son or their shirt on it's okay for the
moderator to look the other weight if
it's just a minor uh violation but I
don't think we should I think we should
keep the uh restriction in place so just
for the neutrality and the safety of the
polling place so that's all I have to
say about it please itl I guess if you
want to ask me questions you're welcome
to whether I'll be able to answer them
or not it's a whole nother
any questions
I have one because I thought I wasn't on
Election law last year but I remember I
thought we passed a bill last year or
something where I would just only
applied to people working
in the election because I was told that
I could walk in with my son my Badges
and and whatever but I couldn't work in
the in the role do you know anything
about that I don't specifically I don't
remember the exact details of the bill I
uh
don't have the RSA 652 in front of me
that uh it's possible but I think it's
still better to keep it the way it was
than probably even
okay
with that
thank you
so anybody else want to speak on the
bill
with that I'll close the hearing on HP
179 and we have a 50 minute break
break out the cards and I mean I'm
joking
it's
thank you Mr chair and thank you fellow
representatives and uh committee members
um for the record my name is Jerry
Cannon
um I represent uh Stratford County
District 12. that's Somersworth and
Rollinsford
this bill was fairly straightforward
we've all been here before we've put out
our signs our campaign signs and or
people put them out for us and then you
go looking for them and they're
disappeared
so you first place to check the highway
department
and usually there's a pile of them
the um
so we'll check a couple of times during
during the campaigns and find signs and
help each other out if if there are
signs of
our fellow campaign
members we try and pick them up and hand
um
we ran into an interesting Challenge and
Summer's worth this bad time and I found
out it's it's happened in other
um
other locations as well
um our
director of the public works department
was out for a couple of weeks
and he left his supervisor in charge and
the statue
and the statute about signs was
specifically political advertising
removed prior to election day
by state city or town maintenance or law
enforcement Personnel shall be kept
until one week after the election at a
place designated by the state city or
town so that the candidate
May retrieve the items and the
um up until this point and running many
times I haven't had that problem I've
usually been able to collect
signs from for fellow Democrats and
having a problem I also ran into one of
the Republicans running for office and
he said he had the same problem
so I looked at the supervisor and I said
so I'm here to change the law
so we've added a few words to it but
essentially it's um
so that the city or town so that the
candidate or a member of the candidates
campaign are local political Committee
of the same party May retrieve
the items
so um that's essentially it because I
wanted to be it I wanted to take care of
my fellow
Democrats and I know my Republican
counterpart wanted to take care of his
us not just for the local folks but
because we had people from out of town
from the state and for national office
that were running and they weren't going
to collect their signs so instead of
taking those signs to the dump I worked
with the uh the uh planning manager of
the city he walked down to the public
works department with me and we
collected all the signs so that's that's
it in a nutshell and I'm recommending
that you ought to pass this bill so we
can not run into this problem again
thank you thank you we have any
questions
okay thank you and just a comment I mean
in the past in my town if they're
collected or gone to the Londonderry
Public Works I mean not the pub the dot
and just picked up all the signs that I
wanted so it's yeah but yeah a good
point that we're changing alone
thank you
and nobody else is here and this was a
five minute
and no more pink cards and
what
oh you turn in a pink card
I don't yeah I did okay
okay oh there it is I'm sorry
my fault
and
we have
two people for it
okay and with that
and close the hearing on
286 and what's that
unless every anybody has any comments we
can probably adjourn